speaking of Brooklyn nine-nine the GLAAD
Media Awards nominations came out this
morning what does that mean to you
because you specifically in your
character of I think a very big part of
that nomination I would say that most of
that credit really goes to Dan or the
show's creator and the writers who
really adamantly feel like our show
should reflect what the world and the
United States looks like and is which
includes people that are in the LGBTQ
community and I think it's so wonderful
that they chose to explore that
storyline with my character I'm really
really proud to be a part of that and
I'm so honored that GLAAD continues to
shine a light on this all of this
incredible work that's happening across
our industry and many others it's really
really really really amazing about
that's amazing you should be really
proud speaking of which how do we
mentally prepare for Gina slash Chelsea
Peretti's
exit chelsea peretti is a gift from the
gods she really is one of the greats I
think the great thing about her quote
unquote leaving the show is that she's
not really leaving
in fact we are shooting an episode with
her coming back very soon so like it's
kind of an interesting thing right it's
like she might not be in every episode
but she's still very much a part of the
world right so I don't think you're
gonna feel it the way that you think you
might if that makes sense right um
Sheena's forever in the fabric of
Brooklyn nine-nine it just wouldn't be
the show without her right so I think
audiences are gonna be really pleased to
see her come back we just did that table
read the other day and it's a really
applier script I can't wait okay so it's
like she graduated from high school and
I was just gonna keep coming back during
the holiday that's exactly right
[Applause]
[Music]